no no
okay so here like when you do
um
it's very easy to want to tilt him do
you see there
right
I want you to feel the center
that's what you're moving you're not
shaking and
the outside shape is a consequence of
the inside shape
I feel from his Center
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
okay so I'm on the front
your that energy is on the function okay
and now
start
keep going
and I'll take it off and you see
so you're pulled I go here
all in my life
okay so I'm going to do the same thing
here
insert the pull
let's feel it a little bit more so you
can feel it
yeah
do you understand so because you're
centering about your Center is over here
not over here if it's here we'll just
stay open
but my body goes in
and then you pull and I ground makes
your Center move do you see
that's what I use so you go full moves
you
not you Paul and then I thought
okay
you pull a ground
here
are you sure I can pull
makes your Center move just like right
eyes
okay so as I start to move in that's
like
same thing go sure
that's how you come back up
you're not good
don't worry about the front end go
okay so go again
you in here
do you see now you're just going to
accelerator backwards pay attention go
sh
are you not here we're gonna go around
and we'll continue
boom not here around my turn
boom not there around tournament
[Music]
big
can be fun
[Music]
okay
don't push on what's pushing on you
don't pull on what's pulling on you
okay so uh live call live I said hey
why'd you go to full
okay
because when they push you're not in any
relationship you're just getting out of
the way
here we go
the pushes it's gonna be on the back
where you go ahead
it's on the back foot and I'm in that
relationship
this this
rebounding energy is what forms the
condensed
so here I saw you just getting out of
the way then you grab it now you have
and like you're rubbing the head and
you're tilting them it's not in here
okay
there you go here
external then you have some of their
body and then you let go of it again and
you will go
he's throwing the head down
oh pressure pressure
in the whole body the whole body look
yeah
oh
so here we have the problem you're like
I know I'm supposed to turn
like you're back on the head only
and it's still rough
he said your whole body
is going to move on that turn
and then the throttle
same thing
I throw the whole box
not the head
anybody
hold the body
whole body
don't lose the connection
not just
hey
everybody
moving in space
foreign
[Music]
here I don't care what his body's doing
you cannot just move the problem
somewhere else and then repeat the same
non-solution okay so there you go just
relax I just want to show you what I
mean okay so you're going around
okay and you're like well I know I could
overpower that but that's not what we do
okay so you're gonna turn it
but if you look at it it's the same
problem
on that little other tank on I tried to
do do you get it
so I can't just go from here and then
turn again
same problem and then enter it's just
not it
so you can't
Go full stuck turn again you're stuck
again now you can't just do it again
do you understand yes
you have to do the solution
so the solution is
feel this
feel
do you see
not if I leave that foot exactly where
it is I will never get off
your body has to move
boom
that way you're already falling
so when I go here oh
are you here and I let go nothing's
happening
am I here and I let go nothing's
happening do you get it so your body I'm
gonna make it go the other way what's
going forward we're going to do a big
circle we're going the other way now
can you see the different geometry
okay
you understand
straight in
even
it's just quick it's small
[Music]
you understand
here boom there
[Music]
okay
remember just like coastview Hall
Coke you home no I gotta do the same
thing
before I enter
okay try it again
so you have your inner spiral
very over you you reverse that and you
have your hours spiral those are your
two movements okay I'm gonna start
making them smaller
and now go okay I don't care about the
handwork but look at my it's on this
questions
but that's what I'm that's what I'm
doing so you get here
and I say still like I'm watching you
and then you go in here but none of us
move nothing remember in what's
happening internally is happening
externally you see so what's happening
internally in my Tom Dirty Field is
happening at the level of my clock
do you remember that's his last video
okay so you're here like this
and you're trying to do it but your Tom
dad is only going well
you see that and so no matter what he's
too heavy
you see you have this has to move
if I can come doesn't matter I can't con
they'll move
if I'm tired doesn't matter
still moves
you understand it's the same thing here
on Pokemon
I don't go
my body has to move
body body moves boom There It Is Going
Back
not here here
[Music]
this is why you can't do it small
foreign
okay so you can do it straight in
straight in just deviate it won't
you can walk towards
but it's in here
our
okay
don't just move your arm into Circle
there you go so uh the the patterns
eluding you the pattern is eluding you
okay but it's actually the same striking
pattern that we do on the makiwara
okay you're you're figurating your
weight
from ground ground path to ground pop
go boom
do you understand
remember there's a video on it oh you're
doing the same thing now we're just
adding the hand movement the hand
movement okay
so it's eluding to you so I'm going to
give you the bigger one
okay we're gonna make it more gross more
external okay so you're gonna get here
and here's where you feel the weight
you don't see that don't move the
problem somewhere else it's not going to
change
you could you could continue to tank on
but you have to change the problem
Okay so
my gross external
is as opposed to doing it on my
legs in place I'm going to actually step
so my weight goes to the front
and then I stepped and there it is right
there
are you going to stretch it out
and in
so here I was
single
this is however we go out
in
out in if you watch the clock it's doing
the same thing
okay
gonna generate the problem
boom there it is and now we're all all
of us will make that big pattern
oh
generate the problem
there it is out
in
[Music]
the problem out in
problem out it
foreign
[Music]
okay
okay so as you shorten the technique
you're taking it
more towards what it would look like in
terms of application remember things are
extended in space and in time for
training purposes
okay but you can't that's a training
environment not an application
environment so as you start doing your
remote or your edema versions
it's not extended
so and it's not extended specially nor
temporally so you got to think about
well what do I want all I need is that
tilt
you see not this big movement
[Music]
and then what why do I want the tilt
once his head's going that way it's
going to expose his face
if you don't understand I just need a
little tilt
and if you remember when we were doing
the sparring videos the Tilt was out
that was all I needed you're not going
to get this big thing like that
so same thing here I go that's it
I don't need the head don't get the head
I'm in the base so the base comes out
boom
as you're going along so just shrink
what you want what you want
you want to shrink what you want
[Music]
it's not his head I want I want his
whole body in space
[Music]
foreign
so you feel
there'll be a resistance on the head
there's a head reaches strong cycle
but that leg down has again so that's
where you go
when the leg reaches its end of its
young cycle here
the arm will pick up the beginning of
its new Young cycle
you get it you just feel that's as far
as I can go that means the legs open who
now I can finish the gay trial